comment les as-tu perdus
le traitement pour ma colonne vertébrale affecte mon
ADN
tu as sacrifié ton pouvoir pour que tu
puisses
bien marcher tu le sais j'ai perdu ma juste
part
sèche tes yeux eric ça ne justifie pas
ce que tu as fait tu n'as aucune idée  ce que j'ai
fait je sais que tu as pris les choses
qui comptent le plus pour moi bien peut-être que tu
aurais dû te battre plus dur pour eux
si tu veux combattre eric je vais
te donner un combat laisse le venir tu
m'as abandonné tu l'as emmenée et  tu m'as abandonné
ange
azazel
emma
banshee
nous étions censés les protéger eric
où étais-tu charles
tu nous as tous abandonnés